the FCC is cracking down on conspiracy
theorists alex jones and they're not the
only ones but is it a violation of free
speech chief congressional correspondent
Mike Emanuel has our report from Capitol
Hill right now infowars.com has been
taken down the FCC has shut down
controversial host Alex Jones's liberty
radio and slapped it with a fifteen
thousand dollar fine which it won't pay
but the Commission says it's been
operating without a license since at
least 2013 and Jones has a conspiracy
theory about what went down oh it's a
private company they can take you down
no this is just so they are
exponentially I believe beta testing
ahead of a big event civil unrest
fascination at trump who knows what the
false flag is a group of false flags
today the FCC Chairman appeared before
the Senate Commerce Committee Rajat
pices Jones's station was taken down
because he was violating the law not
because of the nature of his speech it
is important to make clear that our
pirate radio enforcement efforts
including this one have nothing to do
with the content that pirate radio
stations air the FCC Chairman says this
type of enforcement doesn't typically
get much attention normally our pirate
radio enforcement efforts don't make
national news but this one has because
the pirate radio station in question was
airing Alex Jones as his show Jones is
also getting squeezed by Apple removing
his podcasts facebook youtube linkedin
spotify even pinterest and there's also
an issue with twitter after he posted
this video calling for people to get
their battle rifles ready against the
media chief executive jack dorsey says
he's hoping to modify Jones's tone by
putting him in a Twitter timeout so
whether it works with in this case to
change some of those behaviors and
change some of those actions I don't
know but this is consistent with how we
enforce what President Trump has
complained about Twitter shadow banning
prominent Republicans in calling it a
discriminatory and illegal practice
while Jones with his conspiracy theories
is an easy target there are some who
worried this is a slippery slope where
people with different viewpoints could
be silenced
Brett McMahon
on the hill Mike thanks